foreign
and sometimes it's not love Jade
sometimes they have they've got bones to
pick they got man tears that are have
been grinded and uh producer James sent
us one that David sent in so can I read
it out loud read it out loud with
feeling
thanks for all the entertainment and
advice regarding finances but what I
don't get is why you guys get all
excited when a guy says I just got
engaged or I just got married there's
hand clapping cheers congrats Etc
especially when it's someone in their
early 20s these kids are just too young
to know what they're getting into but
you guys cheer them on unreal fact is
that guy just signed a contract saying
if the marriage doesn't work out which
most don't then there's a good chance
she'll take them to the cleaners and
divorce court we hear about this all the
time there is nothing in it for guys to
get married at all this did not happen
to me I am not married so I am not
bitter or angry women can usually cash
in if it doesn't work out people might
argue that getting married is good
because you have a partner someone to
help you Etc but you can have all of
that without signing a contract saying
you will provide cash and prizes alimony
and or child support when it doesn't
work out in California if you get
divorced after 10 years you will be
paying her forever or until she
remarries I've noticed that in most
marriages soon after the vows the woman
chunks up chops off most of her hair and
starts barking orders at her husband oh
marriage is not like it was 50 years ago
would love to hear what you think thank
you wow David so much to unpack there
and I think you a professional counselor
should do it but you know we'll add some
color commentary to this my guy my guy
sounds like he's been burned George or
absolutely he's jaded one of the two
like wow yeah which you know what as
much as we can pick on David he
represents a large portion of the the
male population who feels this way and
if you don't believe me go to any
YouTube comment section and they're in
there going this is why you should never
get married they'll take you to the
cleaners that's interesting because
there's actually so many great I mean
this is a show about money your life and
your money but there's actually a lot of
great reasons to be married I mean if we
talk about it from the money standpoint
I mean he seems to think that you know
it's it's all about being taken to the
cleaners and it's all about losing out I
mean I definitely have some maybe you're
just picking the wrong lady but you know
there there are definitely some some
positives to being married after being
married 15 years I'd like to think that
there's
yeah I just never once looked at
marriage as this like Financial contract
and who's getting what like that's just
a weird way a weird Spirit to have well
no you definitely don't want to go into
it like that like hey I'm gonna marry
this guy simply because you know that if
you have that attitude and you get
married you probably will get divorced
and it'll be a self-fulfilling prophecy
oh yeah because you went in with
terrible intentions yeah terrible Spirit
side note that just made me think of a
story so my husband Sam who happens to
be sitting out there when we were
engaged he was in his grandfather's will
right to to get money upon death but
there was a a stipulation that said he
had to marry someone Jewish
to get the money and your girl well your
girl is not Jewish so that put us
ultimately to the test wow and Sam chose
me over over the world well how much how
much are we talking here like 10 million
or 20 grand seventy thousand dollars 70
grand you're worth more than 70. I like
to think it's it's great to know that
I'm worth it
but we know that you're at least worth
more than that 100 and I think he's
saying the the ROI is there the Roi he
would do it all over again he better
he's amazing he's better well Jay this
is an interesting conversation because
there's been a lot in the news yes about
marriage and wealth and the power of
couples to build wealth versus someone
who's single or even those that are
cohabitating yes you're shacking up yeah
so what are we finding you know it's
interesting I I read an article on the
Wall Street Journal and they were
talking about this wealth Gap that
you're talking about and they found that
people who were living together just
living together not married
um not even sharing their finances but
they had their net worth was a quarter
of those who were married and sharing
finances wow a quarter that means if
you're married sharing your finances you
are earning three quarters more your net
worth is that much higher yeah here's
here's the numbers if you're curious the
median this is as of 2019 median net
worth for cohabitating couples age 25 to
34 with 17 grand and for married couples
it was 68 Grand and for singles Seven
Grand yeah that that
that is shocking shocking in some ways
but actually George when you really
think about it it's not that shocking
because think about it I'm just thinking
of it from compound interest alone I
mean compound interest on a one person's
say they've contributed ten thousand
dollars right and then the spouse over
here contributed another ten thousand
dollars compound interest isn't helping
you the same as if you had twenty
thousand dollars all in one spot so
there's that then there's a whole
homeowner side of it oh yeah you're more
likely to be a homeowner which is you
know houses appreciate and you're more
likely to be investing you're more
likely to have dual incomes and it's
harder to gain traction as a young
single person than it is as a married
couple and so better together and we
also there's new studies one is from uh
Cornell showing that joint bank accounts
have a higher correlation to longer
lasting and happier marriages that is
very interesting that's a controversial
stance we have is that you should
combine bank accounts and people come at
us with the spirit of David saying oh my
she's gonna take you to the cleaners if
you I don't know why I'm becoming a
wrestler right now but that's the that's
the David voice it's interesting you
know there's got I think the connection
there is that you've you have long-term
planning in mind you've if you're
willing to to combine your finances it
means that hey there's a strong level of
trust which you know it takes trust to
really get anything done and then that
you're really thinking towards the
future you've sat down and you've
planned out which means you're probably
on the same page and you know as well as
I do that when when people when there
where there is no vision the people
perish Dave says it all the time you
know and and I think that when you have
that Vision as a couple as a married
couple you put your money together of
course you're going to go further faster
you're going to do better together yeah
and there's accountability that is built
in when you have a partner because when
you're single you can kind of just like
do your own thing and No One's Gonna
yell at you for going on a retail
therapy spree facts versus Sam going uh
hey I just saw that bank transaction
come through what's going on here let's
have a conversation about it and so that
accountability helps keep you on track
the shared Vision the shared goals and
it's one of the reasons Financial Peace
University is such a powerful tool oh
man change both of our lives and my
spouse works at Ramsey Solutions hey and
so when we started our marriage off I
had already gotten out of debt she was
way smarter than I was and never touched
debt and so we had this crazy goal of
like what if we saved up a huge down
payment and then paid off our house as
quickly as possible wow and so in 26
months we paid off our mortgage uh
actually after the intensity and we did
our debt free scream yes almost a year
ago
and I'm telling you the power to build
wealth when you have a couple that's on
the same page with the same language
shared common language the same goals
shared Vision I mean that's what makes a
power couple Unstoppable Unstoppable you
guys are unstoppable so if you want that
it's available for you and don't listen
to The Hope Stealers out there like
David saying don't get married she's
going to take you to the cleaners
absolutely get rid of that turd attitude
right now okay have a little bit of hope
we need more optimists in this world and
there's plenty of amazing marriages out
there plenty of people who will show you
that it's possible and one of the
reasons is getting on the same page with
money that's right George and it begs to
be said because I gotta say this people
might be listening and going oh if we
just combine our finances that's that's
our golden ticket if y'all are out there
say you're living together but you're
not married do not combine your finances
if you're not married don't come by your
finances yes right we got to say that
because the implications there could be
dire put your ring on go to the
courthouse and then combine your bank
accounts and by the way if you're one of
these guys that's been dating a girl for
like eight or nine she's waiting on the
Rings yeah man she's been waiting too
long homegirl's about to bounce if you
don't commit come on son so that's just
a PSA to all the Jeffs out there if your
name is Jeff and your good guy I'm sorry
but I just had to use someone's name
that's Jeff Scott
goodness what's a good good conversation
David we picked on you but we do
appreciate the email and thank you for
listening you can send in your feedback
at ask at ramseysolutions.com